hello everyone and welcome back to the
Lindor s heavy rapid challenge we are at
Game three in the third match Magnus
Carlsen versus Hikaru Nakamura and like
I said this is match three game one
ended in a draw and he called one game -
so now Magnus needs to win a game to get
back into the match and then who knows
what can happen in Game four if it's a
draw then maybe we'll go into Armageddon
or maybe it can even finish before going
tour mageddon but first Magnus needs to
equalize so for this occasion Magnus
decides to go for d4 we have nightly of
six by Hikaru c4 e6 Knight to f3 and of
course d5 we go into the Queens gambit
declined Knight to c3 and Bishop to e7
with bishop therefore by Magnus and just
castles by heck are we
III preparing to develop the light
square bishop and Knight B to d7 and as
usual black is waiting for whites to
develop the light square bishop before
capturing and c4 which is what happens
here we have Bishop to e2 and now trying
to get a white - I had to waste a move
by recapturing and c4 but Magnus decides
that he will play without recapturing so
here Magnus castles and not nice to be
sexy core defends the pawn at least for
the moment we have Queen to c2 by Magnus
and now there is one game in the
database we're Knights
the h5 was played it was played in 2012
between onigiri and Levin Aragon Aragon
was able to win that game with this nice
to h5 maneuver I was in the Tata Steel
masters edition but here the night goes
to d5 and with this shifting of the
night we have a new game so already as a
move 9 we have a completely new game and
as the bishop is under attack Bishop to
g4 so c5 by kick are now challenging
Carlsen Center and D captures and c5 and
c5 which will make it possible to bring
the rook over to d1 and then maybe
attack the knight with the e4 pawn so
Bishop captures and c5 and now rook F to
D 1 now efore is of course a threat that
will just win the night the queen is
still on d8 so Bishop to d7 by Hikaru
now if you attack the knight the knife
can just move and night e
five now an excellent outpost for
tonight and well if you don't want to
play some like f6 the night is pretty
much staying there so look the c8 by
Hikaru and rook a to c1 by Magnus still
the black is up upon but the white is
getting a lot of development and a lot
of crucial squares for his pieces so
here he car goes night to be for now now
maybe it was worth considering you have
six to kick away the night but it's
always an ugly moved to play so he Carl
instead goes nights the B for attacks
Carlson's Queen and cousin goes Quinta
efore puts pressure on the b7 pawn so he
Carl just goes back night for to d5 now
blocks the Queens attacked at a b7 pawn
and Magnus just shifts the Queen to f3
so by doing this maneuver night the B
for back to the five Hikaru basically
just shifted Carlson's Queen from c2 to
f3 which is a which is a better square
putting pressure on f7 putting pressure
on b7 and well it's it's just a much
better square for the Queen then c2 also
now the rooks are a nicely placed on c1
and the d1 and here a hit car should go
for for Queen to e7 you should get the
Queen away from from the D file but it's
also a very unpleasant line because
after all of the trades let's say
characters captures you're gonna go
characters captures the knight has to
capture and now you're gonna pick up the
b7 pawn and you continue playing this
game but after Knight b6 black should
have a very nice game you offer a queen
trade and do you bring the other book
into the game and so on
however he car went for Bush up to a
four he offered the trade here putting
pressure on the rook on d1 but this
again opens up this well D file for the
rook which Magnus immediately takes
advantage of so Knight captures on a
four-night characters and just efore so
winning that winning that night well not
really but you will you will give up the
rook for four do pieces from Knight
captures and b2 by Nakamura and now he
captures on d5 we have nightcap force
and e1
nakamura grabs the rook rook captures
and e1 and now he captures on d5 and now
Magnus doesn't go for the for this point
but rather Bishop captures and c4 white
take one point when you can take two
points and only on the next move will
you capture
so here Queen to e7 putting pressure on
the night and also just getting the
Queen away from the D file and only now
Bishop captures and d5 and now with a
double attack on the b7 pawn and here he
car goes to Bishop to d6 now with a
double attack on the night however this
also doesn't do all that much for black
as Magnus immediately goes through
Bishop captures on f7 with the check and
you cannot capture the bishop problem is
if you capture with real characters on
f7 then just Knight captures and then it
doesn't matter how you continue if you
if you capture here then just Queen
captures with checked in captures and
now you pick up the bishop here which
leaves you being upper for peace or
after Knight characters you could go for
Bishop captures and g3 first but then
you have Knights to h6 check and now the
problem is if you move the King then
Knight f5 attacks the Queen and we'll
pick up the Bishop that way and you will
end up for being up a piece or you
capture the night and then just queen g4
check picks up the rook on c8 like king
of seven Queen captures here and then
you are just up an exchange and well
completely winning so after Bishop
captures n f7 Hikaru goes back King to
h8 but now Queen to h5 now still keeping
an eye on on the bishop on the knight
but also as the Bishop is covering the
g8 Square D the real threat is Knight to
g6 checkmate as the pawn will be unable
to recapture so here Nakamura goes
Bishop characters on e5 but it is
insufficient feel free to pause the
video and win this game for Magnus while
I give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations unsporting that first we
need to take care of the bishop and only
then capture on e5 and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
Bishop captures sorry Bishop to g6 no
captures obviously and now you will
still recapture on e5 but first you're
threatening checkmate here so h6 here
are must play this and now Bishop
characters on e5 introducing another
threat of Queen captures on h6 because
this pawn will be unable to recut to
recapture so Queen g5 Nakamura has to do
something he offers a queen trade but
Magnus happily accepts Queen captures
captures and now h4 making room for
King and also just now enjoying this
this end game where white will have two
bishops two bishops against the rook
so rook the c5 kicker of course still
has two rooks and for a moment he will
he will try to make them fully
operational
so the Shabak the b2 we looked the b5
again attacking the bishop and now
Bishop the a3 putting pressure on the
rook here look the c8 and only now h5 so
that's now a very strong a pawn we have
looked at a five now he caught a
whirlwind d8u pawn and better back to
beat you now we have rook captures a
native in the now rook to d2 defending
that bishop and now preparing to bring
this bishop to be one to kick away the
rook so King to g8 as you have some
problems here for example if you move
the rook anywhere and then just work
here will be checkmate so you kind of
need to bring the King into the game so
Bishop to be one kicking away the rook
and rook to a5 and only now look the d7
the two bishops are preventing the rook
from doing any any lifting and here
hikaru goes for rook the b5 now the
bishops are under attack however it's
very easy to you know get out of the
attack with Bishop to a two track so
King to h7 and now comes Bishop captures
on g7 there is not much not much for
black to do here we have g4 by Hikaru
going for that pawn here but now Bishop
to e5 a discovery from the rook we have
King to h6 and now Bishop the f4 check
forcing forcing the the King to capture
on h5 so King captures and now Bishop to
f7 with check we have king to h4 and now
kink to h2 now Magnus is preparing just
just the g3 to checkmate the black king
a so Hikaru needs to make some room for
is king he pushes g3 himself with check
Magnus grabs it and now King to g4 but
it is again insufficient since all of
these words are covered the the way to
victory is fairly easy so Bishop to e6
check Magnus goes back King to h5 and
now rook to h7 check opening up a
discovery on the rook here came to g6
attacking the rook
but now rook to h6 check and now once
the King moves you will just pick up the
rook and that's it
so King the g7 and here at Magnus just
picked up the rockin c8 and it was in
this position unmoved 46 that Hikaru
Nakamura resigned the game and Magnus
equalizes the score so now the score is
even and we have a game for coming up
which we will not be showing as game 4
ended in a draw so what we will be
showing is Armageddon
so next video is the Armageddon game
between magnets and Hikaru we'll see
what happens there I will just say that
it was Hikaru who chose whatever he
wants to be white or black and Hikaru
chose black as he always does at one
time he said that he he he's faster than
all the other players I don't know if he
was talking about magnets as well but he
said that he was faster than other
players so it doesn't bother him all
that much to have less the less time on
the clock and you only need a draw so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
we'll be seeing you in the in the
Armageddon game so stay tuned I would
like to thank Tebow Rosenblatt Yoseob
governor and Randall wall and Karen max
Nietzsche and Jacob bank for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos
serum thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the Lindor s IV rapid Charlie checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your Sunday